天才時計師との初めて社長です俺はなぁそれないぞ
ドッキリされても失敗してもまあ全く懲りないためねー
多分もう今回は相手も相手だしもうやることもやることなんで確実にビビります
もう多分ねーわーってなることはもうもう目に見えてるんで今回一人なかったろっ
これドッキリやれますから確実にやりますあけてないんだけど
いただけますねうわぁ良い
そうでした寒気したよやばっ
リズムが俺6にこれ大丈夫か
これはねちょっとヤバいんですよえっ
ずうを
以上分
ています
よねほんとに守り切った
だから自分で買ったうちに本当に強いすごい
を付けこれなら玩具おもちゃなん
ターンを持つはやっぱやばいなーこれ死んじゃうよ本当に
うーん
すげーっとに見えた
予防
それもは大丈夫でねっ
本来畑なぁこちらでそちらの
音が5球目です
やばいよもうねはら年たもねもう完璧なんですよ
完全にゴキブリを再現してこの大きさよ
ん
俺の最も信頼できる友達巧みに
ちょっと今から多分もうすぐ遊びに来るんですよそれで匠が遊びにくるんで
あいつらはもうねだけ現在いいリアクションしてくれると思うんで
まあ日頃の感想を込めでず国のどん底に落とすてやろうと思います
いくぜ行こう入って行けて今店なんですけど
生き物系のドッキリではこうアクションして初めてびっくりするんで置いてあるだけ
じゃダメなんで
今回は今回はここに仕掛けますなんなのこれ
もう何5球目においてみたいな感じ
どうすよ
コーダーなんですこんな感じこんな感じいっ
コーナー幸田棒だこうします
って感じなんですよ落ちれかわかんねーなー
んアーチがう
まっす
いいでしょだいたいはもう止まったんでザートゎターゲットを待ちます
キュッ
ヶ月飽きたんだん
次3
硫黄系
ん
ありゃ一般で入ってきてまゆキュッ
はい
goo ああああああああ
rar
持った
tj ん
ムラー my blog 今回の時いえば大成功
じゃーん
英泰星号 hey
道
破けないそれ
yeah